school is presenting its new octavia
station wagon the combi at Lake chiemsee
Bavaria the sales figures prove this is
one of the most popular station wagons
in Europe Scott is introducing the
latest model Octavia to increase its
market share in Western Europe dr. vs
Gaddafi for scooters Hammond schmidt
explains that the Octavia station wagon
accounts for over one third of sales and
the company hopes to expand the share
station wagon is a key factor there's
also a sedan version of course but the
station wagon is especially important
because it makes up some ninety percent
of octavia sales in Germany Octavia for
Kayla that reflects approximately the
percentage of the overall sales and it
didn't balloon sickman with a length of
four metres 66 the wagon is as robust as
any skoda the transmission and steering
are tight and handling is good via test
Aeneid artist driver Chris took out the
1.6 litre turbocharged direct-injection
version listed at twenty thousand seven
hundred forty euros the smallest
gasoline powered version starts at
sixteen thousand six hundred forty euros
a tad in rated consumption of 3.8 liters
per hundred kilometers at an official 99
grams of co2 per kilometer the emissions
are quite acceptable prices too
the station wagons front is identical
with the sedans the hood to grill and
the headlights everything
the line sweep dynamically from the
front to rear windows
but the rear can seem a bit off-putting
parking sensors are standard
the extreme glossy coffee crisp is
impressed by the Octavia station wagons
extremely large cargo space he says he'd
fit into the 610 litres space twice over
and this little lever turns the 610
litres into 1740 that's about eighty
five liters more than its predecessor
the interior has many convenient details
in store the electronically adjustable
seats for instance with a memory for
personalized sitting positions
in the center console are the radio and
several assist systems including of
course parking assist
skoda has aggressive plans for the
market with several more models soon to
be released
yazoo kada and fo I'm on Schmidt's
oscoda is in a face of product fireworks
that began in the middle of last year
the city goat is an entirely new model
for a whole new segment a variation of
the Euro feed is the space back Skuta
will be face lifting the superb before
the end of the year and the Yeti by
early next year in 2014 it's the Fabia
stern so by the end of next year the
entire range of models will have been
updated festivals will complete them
with a pilot wouldn't I know it's his on
to sum up the Octavia station wagon
chris has no complaints whatsoever about
the driving qualities it drives smoothly
and pleasantly with the consumption of
just 3.8 liters per hundred kilometers
it's a car for hauling loads and saving
fuel a car worthy of its predecessors
audi's r8 e-tron in its technology offer
a glimpse of the future and a hint of
just how emotional and flexible
electromobility can be
i'm nanette a theater on our out a
spokesman says they presented the r8
e-tron as a technology highlight a
trailblazer for development in other
words they can apply the technology test
it and develop it for series production
so future series produce cars can
benefit from it things at him with it at
all the r8 e-tron has a 280 kilowatt
power house with a maximum torque of a
brute 820 Newton meters it boasts an
impressive range of 215 kilometers all
these vitamin C explains that inside
what's normally the transmission hump is
a battery shaped like a tea the front
part has to sell levels in the back part
behind the seats has four cell levels
all together the battery weighs 500 77
kilos he says it's the heart of the car
and the Fox the moto phone in faults
like the car has left and right electric
motors they work independently so the
right one drives the right wheel and the
left the left wheel the unique
configuration allows for a kind of
torque vectoring meaning that when it
corners the outer wheel the left one
here has to drive harder so more power
can be shifted onto that one into
thought it was maybe luster the size we
could not mere cuff to vote on he
continues saying this car makes use of
what he calls recuperation which means
that since normal driving mainly uses
the rear wheel brakes and the electric
motors are directly coupled to these
wheels when the driver takes his foot
off the pedal the braking energy can be
recuperated and fed back into the
battery negative sewak devonian and dims
inner on the day liquid anybody realized
but the series is set to remain small
only 13 units have been built because
Audi opted to conduct further tests and
research into electromobility
well not this elddis Heiner Metzger
explains that the Electra was developed
parallel to the normal our age but only
the doors were the same everything else
on the e-tron was an made out of carbon
fiber and the interior had been
completely redesigned compared to the
normal r8 he says Audi developed new
rims especially for the r8 e-tron when
the car is stopped they opened up to
cool the brakes speeds exceeding 50
kilometers an hour the centrifugal force
pushes these side blades in to enhance
the cars aerodynamics the r8 e-tron
weighed in at seventeen hundred and
eighty kilos the body structure
including side panels came to barely 200
kilos 23 kilos less than the normal r8
even the glass rear window was replaced
with a carbon fiber panel to reduce
weight even more young at us come on
let's get points out the system that
replaces the rearview mirror the view
back is obstructed so a camera is used
to show what's back there on an o LED
display mounted where the review mere
would be the system was tried for the
first time on the r18 LeMond adopted for
the r8 e-tron auspol beaut will be on
this union after gonna win the r8 e-tron
makes the sprint from 0 to 100
kilometers an hour in 4.2 seconds tires
squealing included are there any other
sound yummy and easing fought cycles
Metsker says audi developed the sound
especially for the r8 e-tron they were
aiming for a mix of a futuristic and a
familiar combustion sound even standing
still the car purrs to warn pedestrians
of its presence annoys varies depending
on how hard the driver steps on the gas
or how much energy the car is using just
to enhance the feeling of being in
motion a new job offer on buying offices
and disagreeing akatsuki full of MIT
sawdust relation
but in terms of the future Audi's r8
e-tron will remain a model used to
research the technology that may be used
in series produced electro cars
VW is extending its cross series with
another model the cross caddy the new
crossover model comes with increased
Headroom in the front and back making it
well suited for family or commercial use
among the off-road features that make it
a real eye-catcher our new bumpers and
door sills 17 inch tires and wheel arch
protectors the cross caddy has a 63
kilowatt gasoline-powered engine under
the hood and sells for just under 19
thousand euros in Germany there's a
four-wheel drive model to Mercedes
latest 4-door high-performance midsize
kupe is the cla45 AMG the resemblance to
the CLS 63 AMG is intentional the 355
horsepower engine complies with euro 6
emission standards and is said to be the
most powerful four-cylinder car to be
built in the series a twin-scroll
exhaust turbocharger helps give the low
volume turbo the unfit needs to please
most any driver the AMG is fitted out
with a 7-speed dual-clutch transmission
and all-wheel drive the car is due to go
on sale in September
audit assistant to a test driver Sasha
cannot will be taking the new coupe a
version of the Hyundai i30 out for a
spin German head designer Thomas
Berkeley wanted to create a sporty look
for the car which he achieved by
installing new daytime running lights
fog lights and a dark hexagonal grille
the coop a is the third in line of i-30
compact cars coming after the five-door
hatchback and station wagon models it's
dynamic design since the coop a apart
from its two predecessors
besides wise in terms of measurements
the three-door car is in no way inferior
to the 5-door both are four point three
meters long with identical widths and
Heights the designs however are a bit
different just like its siblings the i30
Kupe began its life in the Hyundai
European tactical centre in whistles hi
its wheelbase is also long enough to
provide maximum comfort for all five
seats
you
the sporty 16-inch light alloy wheels
are a standard feature of the series
in the coop Sasha explains that although
there are fewer doors the two in front
are 17 centimeters longer making it
easier to get into the back seats on the
phone for nothing Einstein Cup Hyundai
really went to town when it came to
furnishing and designing the interior
the front seats are sporty yet
comfortable and can be easily pushed
forward with a simple mechanism
an optional panoramic glass roof lets in
plenty of light and can be opened
the dashboard design is very similar to
that of the hatchback and station wagon
drivers can choose between the classic
and design looks it also has a six-speed
manual gearbox the option of a six-speed
automatic only comes with powerful
gasoline and diesel models
in on zonta stock Sasha's test car has
the design interior with an orange camel
color theme running through the seat and
the seams of the steering wheel and gear
stick together with the 1.6 crdi engine
with 94 kilowatts of power the car costs
20 1760 euros not including the glass
roof done on the speculation it it may
be better that shorter passengers sit in
the back since the roof slants off quite
radically 960 couples Tasha concedes
that there is less Headroom than the
5-door version but the legroom is
identical with yang defy advice is
buying the rear view camera for 1020
euros the structure at the back doesn't
provide visibility to the rear that is
as good as it is in the 5-door there are
still more new features to discover on
the outside so did Sasha takes us to the
back to show us the new taillights a
lowered back bumper and the horizontally
fitted fog lights oh it's important
liebe Jennifer
the wide rear of the i30 Kupe makes a
sporty impression the distinctive
horizontal lines draw undeniable
parallels to the rear of the one series
BMW
and we mustn't forget the roof spoiler
whether it's integrated brake lights
avoid Sasha tells us that even though
it's a coupe a there is still just as
much space in the trunk as with the
five-door model there is 378 liters of
storage space which expands the 1316
leaders if the back seats are folded
down this leaves plenty of uncompromised
storage space which allows for the
securing of cargo with hooks instead of
a spare the trunk comes with a repair
kit
fires have a choice between two gasoline
and two diesel engines we're driving the
powerful diesel model
it can reach speeds of up to 197 km/h
though it needs almost 11 seconds to go
from nought to 100 and here we come to a
flaw of the otherwise very satisfactory
I 30 kupe the scope a leg one Sasha
thinks it should make a sporty or
impression and that can't be achieved
with its current engine he thinks it's
too similar to the hatchback and wagon
to us 12 the 1.6 crdi engine with 94
kilowatts has to be pushed forward to
run anything like a sports car he admits
that that would also push her
consumption level much higher as well so
he would prefer it if the car at a
little more umph escapada unfinished
pepero moto Winston the basic gasoline
model of the i30 Kupe is available in
Germany from fifteen thousand six
hundred euros
the concorso d'eleganza at the Villa
desta on Lake Como is one of the world's
leading and most long-standing classic
car events
you will never see so many beautiful
cars so many passionate people despite
to whether this is the best place to be
then the environment our test driver
Martha Stewart says that sitting in the
car like this lagonda makes him feel
like The Great Gatsby having that you
rarely see cars like this on the street
Martha says the place to see them is
that premier classic car shows like the
concours d'elegance avilla desta on Lake
Como it's a perfect place for a brand
like Aston Martin to celebrate special
birthdays the British sports car maker
would have turned 100 this year the
Aston Martin's here are all privately
owned these wheels would be a credit to
any factory museum the high-class owners
show typically I class reserved more
than 50 classic cars can be seen here
all of them are worth millions artworks
on wheels the undisputed star of the
show is this 1938 bugatti 57sc atlantic
only for the streamlined cars were ever
built one fetched more than 23 million
euros at option in 2010 making it one of
the world's most expensive cars this one
belongs to fashion designer ralph lauren
I love beautiful cars whether they're
very modern noveria or old contemporary
or pre-war but I love all cards a
spectacular example of a car from the
roaring 20s is this sky blue open tura
with a design based on the 1928
rolls-royce phantom one at a seven point
seven liter engine under the hood that
shows the cool that they got the owner
Alexander schauffler says the concours
is his favorite show after Pebble Beach
it's the world's second-best classic
event and certainly the best in Europe
meet nice people and see cars it's a
great honor to be invited but son of
alternate Labatt's a son named in his
letters points out that alongside the
classics are visionary concept cars like
the gran Lusso the result of a BMW and
feenin Farina cooperation by its mission
bmv on pininfarina and stuntin is this
glimpse of the future not only left us
thinking of a new series of coup pays
but BMW as well
I'm new so Isis Watson bmw's Cody Habib
tells us the car is a gran Lusso and as
the name implies it's about GT or gran
turismo and gone musa or luxury he has
that the design philosophy is of course
dynamic after all it's a BMW so its
sporting but it's also elegant safe and
flawless with lines running from front
to back respective two wheelers are also
welcome at the Concours d'Elegance a BMW
is using its event patronage to
celebrate 90 years of BMW bikes your
concept studies are a must
invista behind Lisa bMW says the brand
represents functionality and performance
he notes however the precision and
emotion also go with the bike which many
people may not expect from BMW he says
it's especially pleasing to him that the
motorcycle is so well received the
concept 90 model makes an optical
reference to the 1973 BMW r90s it's to
be produced in series with similar lines
on the second day of the event the cars
cruise over to the nearby villa album
where the public is invited to join in
classy car enthusiasts are thrilled came
to one man says they claim to like lemon
is here and it's a pleasure to be there
right I need us it was something there
spend us his phone other mentions that
this is a premier event worldwide he
adds they knew they had to come and now
they're here saying the cars are out of
their price range but it's nice to see
them anyway of all of you in pashwan
Susie in yo the auto cars the atmosphere
it's a great day this man enthusiasts
the high point of judging in the contest
for the best looking car is the stroll
or drive by to have a look the prices
can increase the value of the automobile
enormously
the rolls-royce open Turing drives off
with a trophy and value at it as well
ralph lauren's Bugatti wins the gold cup
at the 2013 concorso d'eleganza has
everyone expected
Ben Mon Mar and Monta says it might be
an idea to drop in on the next concours
if you happen to be in the Lake Como
area sometime in late May it's a place
to see wonderful cars and have
interesting conversations and he's off
to do just that right now